lorsque la bande dessinée inspire le
théâtre et que la pièce est jouée dans
l'enceinte même d'un palais de justice
cela se passe à nantes en ce moment le
général alcazar comparaît devant la cour
d'assises pour l'enlèvement et la
séquestration du professeur tournesol en
l'absence de tintin mais en présence de
vrais professionnels du monde judiciaire
le public se retrouve véritablement
ballotté entre le vrai et le faux voyez
ces reportages de josée st paul et
thierry poirier
l'instant est solennel le public se lève
pour l'entrée de la cour
nous sommes dans l'enceinte du palais de
justice de nombreux athlètes pour juger
de la culpabilité que monsieur
francisque où elle cazères va commencer
l'accusé et le général alcazar en
pétrole personnage ambigu bien connu des
lecteurs de d'intérêt d'avoir participé
à l'enlèvement du professeur tournesol
les seuls éléments dont nous disposions
se trouve dans le récit des les sept
boules de cristal comédien et
professionnels jouent côte-à-côte lui
intérêts de contrôle
il est huissier de justice dans la vie
c'était moi un garagiste qui aurait
assisté à l'enlèvement du professeur
tournesol cette info un véritable jeu de
devinettes l'africain du général alcazar
indre et vous souvenez vous des plantes
pas trop improviser
alors que dans une affaire d'assises il
y à des improvisations à tout moment des
coups de théâtre là
forcément les coups de théâtre sont un
peu prévu l avance tintin et le
capitaine haddock ne témoigne pas les
auteurs se sont attachés au second rôle
comme pour rendre hommage à tous ceux
qui accompagnaient tintin dans ses
aventures
la pièce s'adresse plus particulièrement
aux tintinophiles mais certains
spectateurs sont aussi venus pour le
décor
moi je n'ai jamais assisté à un procès
quels qu'ils soient donc
on est un petit peu impressionné je
dirais ses livres le palais et puis
la justice est rendue au nom du peuple
français des banques
les gens viennent les gens voient
comment ça fonctionne qu'est ce que ça
fait d'être sur le banc des accusés et
bien c'est assez impressionnant parce
que je n'oublie pas que ici il se passe
des choses tragiques et que cet épisode
comique ne doit pas nous faire oublier
la cour un répondu le général alcazar un
truc contre l'acquittement de l'accusé
après une délibération record 5 minutes
seulement aux moeurs et acquitté et le
public après une courte hésitation aux
applaudir dans celui impressionnant le
tribunal le temps d'un spectacle s'est
transformé en théâtre